pants going bros my name is Sam today
I'm going to bake with someone very
special my gf marzia clap it up
everybody its Marcia cha-cha-cha way my
say coming up coming up
finally we haven't cooked in so long we
always do it on your channel but today
special day cooking on my channel with
my sin may I say you look very beautiful
today
no my dad thank you for caring about the
pros we'll do it after the video when
we're done making the Transformers
cupcakes my my my face I want an ice
watching me die off okay okay okay but
it's my favorite
important to my American I have a lot of
questions hahaha so why don't you
instruct us how you could because you're
my senior always make such delicious
cake for me okay for your mother
what do you mean eat it off of your bond
okay and again we're going to do that
okay just its pre-mixed so we are they
don't even have to do any crowd from the
ground okay okay okay you know I love
when you speak Italian my skin
my name I want to go I'd mop it up
you're not allowed to see this why don't
we practice together as a symbol of our
child everyone ever had
I don't think this is the right thing to
crack it on yes wait this one they say
this is the biscuit mix and this is the
icing Oh
but okay there's ago this is both yeah
[Music]
I'll record any bacteria and what a
superior by what oh yeah right hey em
and back area and back area
no thank you all right how much butter
should be fun
all of these oh yeah this is highway it
doesn't that seem a little much should
we have melted at first I don't know
what my said you are good at cooking I
don't understand you act so different
today
it's almost like you're another person I
could
to navigate I wouldn't have agreed on
our lecture my god yes why now I
remember just part of it this is really
this is a really good last night
yeah show show the audience waiting your
student so we're working on my economic
sense so I can sit in here you guys
really can I hear boy you say celery why
do you think I'm so turned on pretty
sexy right
[Music]
but pure butter
oh you guys are you're nothing when you
get it oh my gosh yes
[Music]
don't fit it's a little loose just a
little loose right your man you know
you're not supposed to talk about my
mother like that
how much that's enough be perfect booty
shake okay you see okay cowboy hat it
looks like a cowboy hat and now we put
it in the oven
yes 416 me 15 minutes
why should we do it for 15 minutes oh
[Laughter]
[Music]
that was amazing
Bobby be Bedfordshire ever had every
time of year is the best
oh my god it's so nice yeah we're
cooking it looks like a cowboy actually
kinda tough why don't you have a camera
norm today normally you have my place
yeah we're forced to do things Cornell
Tyler I don't like them anymore ah okay
I think is pretty hot are we actually no
it's love that lost time oh wow it comes
off just like a real cookie oh you're
crazy like it today are you getting up
in Tahoe ready
[Music]
mmm-hmm
that is good Wow
I get it cookie with money you're so
goodness thank you
why don't we just really strange since
I've never started in the face like this
in all the knife in my 24 years of my
writer story Jerry what are you talking
to you but I thought you were gee how'd
this happen
[Music]
Who am I
I want to be bested especially when your
mouth
[Laughter]